[Music]
new tonight at 11 they are terms we're
starting to hear
more and more cryptocurrency bitcoin and
nfts now it basically all boils down to
a digital way to buy and sell
goods oracle man explains how it works
and why it is exploding in popularity
you can buy trade sell convert
cryptocurrency lets you buy goods and
services online it uses technology known
as blockchain which records all
transactions
bitcoin is the most well-known
cryptocurrency
a lot of people again really think this
is the future of money andrew grechko
with coupon cabin says its popularity is
rising
according to a recent coupon cabin
survey 89 percent of americans have
heard of crypto currencies with more
people buying in each day gretchco says
that's because of the speed of
transactions
you're cutting out a lot of banks in
most instances so you are going to then
create a middleman less space if i
wanted to send you money i can do that
much quicker
some las vegas casinos use
cryptocurrency and local businesses are
doing it too
max pond accepts cryptocurrency on
sales so you can make a purchase you
want to buy a watch for five thousand
dollars
also sold on blockchain are nfts which
are essentially digital collectors items
the vegas golden knights just announced
their first collection of nfts it's a
limited run of only eight in the
inaugural batch gretchko says while they
cost a pretty penny
they come with exclusivity and bragging
rights
i know with the golden knights there's
going to be very few mints of those ever
created so there's definitely kind of a
gold rush if you will to get those
orc omana 8 news now